We're voting on House Resolution 63.
All those in favor of Vote II.
When the bell rings,
those opposed vote no.
As every member voted
as any member was to change there may
now.
On whether or not to expel Justin Pierson
will be announced.
The vote is 69 26 nays.
I received the consent
the concurrence of two thirds
of the members to which the House
is entitled on the Constitution.
The State of Tennessee House Resolution
63 is hereby adopted. Without objection.
The motion reserves
table pursuant to Article
two, Section 12,
and Constitution Fantasy.
I hereby declare.
Representative Justin Jay Pearson.
Here's Justin Pearson.
As you're just sitting right
there has been expelled with 69 votes
in favor to expel him.
We needed 66 votes
to announce a formal expulsion.
He has now been expelled.
Joining Justin Jones,
who had also been expelled.
Gloria Johnson survived her seat
with 65 votes
just one vote saving her seat.
Folks, I have to tell you the optics
there, as Gloria
Johnson referenced herself,
perhaps the only white out of the three
Congress members
there and representatives
that had been saved her seat.
So there you see it.
The Tennessee House
voting to expel two of the three
Democratic lawmakers for their objection
to gun legislation.
Two weeks ago.
This is the culmination of that.
This is a historic moment right now,
as your say, playing out
state legislature there in Tennessee.
What happened today?
The expulsion of two representatives
in the Tennessee
statehouse has only happened twice
since the 1860s.
The last expulsion in 2016
was for a lawmaker
accused of sexual misconduct.
This time
it was for a violation of the rules
of decorum.
Gary Tuchman is inside the state capitol,
just outside the House
chamber joins us now.
So Gary, talk about
what's just happened now.
Anderson, as we speak behind me,
there are about 150
very angry people angry that legislators
have been expelled
from the House of Representatives
right here.
I'm standing
between Tennessee
state troopers right here
and the people back
they are standing here
is because the legislators are coming
out of the door
now, a legislative chamber, and there's
any possibility of violence
but so far, peaceful
people playing dead, lying down here,
it's fine.
But the people are watching here
and fighting passes over the bit more
people very angry and they wander back.
Hundreds of people outside and inside
the legislature building the Capitol
and the people inside who are now leaving
to come out here, basically to show
that there's
one of the legislators
who are coming out right now
That in a nutshell,
that's a political story.
And here is the man
who he's just expelled.
This is just in Houston.
I don't know if you can see him,
but Justin Pierce is now walking out.
Most of the people
in this we get a legitimate
representative person
to person.
How do you feel when, sir?
How do you feel?
How do you feel right now, sir?
Well, he's not talking right now.
It's hard for me to get to work.
How is Mr.
Representative,
how do you feel right now?
Is that how you feel?
It doesn't
it's pretty chaotic,
as you can see, holding
get back towards our camera.
It's a chaotic scene.
But to put this on nonpolitical nutshell,
these people
have been expelled
from the House of Representatives
because they walked out of turn
last week.
Seven days ago,
they walked out of turn,
not allowed to walk into the well,
the House of Representatives
without permission
from the speaker of the House.
They did that to protest this.
And they also talk about the turn.
And one week later, they're expelled.
Listen to what people are saying.
No justice, no peace. Take a look
at
the two representatives expelled.
The other one,
Gloria Johnson, survived by one vote.
Gloria Johnson, who is white
and Justin Johnson is black.
People have said on the record
they believe
it has something to do with skin color.
We don't know the answer to that.
But two of the three legislators expelled
are no longer representatives.
They were elected by tens
of thousands of people
in their districts,
but they've now been expelled
from the House of Representatives
by Tennessee state legislators.
Anderson, back to you.
And Gary,
what what are their options now?
The two legislators
who have been expelled,
will they run again?
So here's something very interesting.
You're going to talk to
Justin Jones shortly.
He'll tell you if he's to run again,
but really into the Tennessee law
if he decides to run again
and he wins again,
he can't be charged on these
same counts again. That's interesting.
It's double jeopardy here
because you decide the election against
you can't be excluded on this term.
However,
they could find other charges to expel.
That doesn't mean
he wouldn't be expelled again.
You just can't be expelled.
Of this charge of disorderly behavior.
That's what the Republicans are saying.
He could a disorderly behavior.
These people just said
they wanted to get their words across
about the gun issue
and they weren't being allowed to talk.
And that's why they walked into the well.
That's why they talked in order to get
the words out
that their constituents
wanted him to say.
That's what they say
and they won't be permitted to do so.
What's remarkable about this incident,
since it was only one week ago
when other people here
were expelled from this legislature,
we know of only three cases since 1866.
It was because of crimes or issues.
We have had
never been an issue or a break in a war.
I've covered a lot of state legislatures
in my career for 40 years.
People break rules all the time.
They don't get it.
So this is very unusual
for Republicans
we're talking to this necessary
because it disrupted
lives here.
But that being said, it is most unusual.
All right.
Gary Tuchman,
we're going to come back with you
We're going to continue to follow this.
Continue with those.
We're going to reposition our camera.
President Biden is following this story,
quoting now from his tweet
a short time ago.
Quote Three kids and three officials
gunned down in yet another mass shooting.
And what are GOP officials
focused on
punishing lawmakers
who joined thousands
of peaceful protesters calling for action
The president adding it is
it's shocking, undemocratic
and without precedent.
Now, shortly,
we're going to talk to Justin Jones,
who is one of the representatives
who was expelled just a few hours ago.
The representative who was just expelled,
as Gary Tuchman was talking about,
who was just leaving the House floor.
That's Justin Pierson
Gloria Johnson, as you know,
a third representative who also took part
in this protest last week.
She survived the vote to expel her
by one vote.
Let's see if we can hear
some of what Justin Pierson is saying
up
The status quo is not working.
It's hurting people.
It's killing people.
And they're treating things like this
as normal.
We can never normalize
the ending of democracy.
We can never normalize the tyranny
of the way that these people
in positions of power
operate due to white supremacy
and due to the maintenance of patriarchy.
That's what we're up against.
But we are going to fight it
because we believe
that there is a future
that we can live into
that is better than the present
that we currently have.
Any other questions
that
we're going
to keep fighting for people in Nashville?
So, again, that's just a person
who has now been expelled.
And again,
this is from a protest
that took place last week.
These three members stood up,
approach the well to speak.
They didn't
have permission to speak
They used bullhorns
to try to get their point across.
They were speaking
in the wake
of the mass murder of nine people
at at the school in in Nashville.
Do we have Justin Jones?
Okay.
We're waiting to hear from Justin Jones.
Gloria Johnson,
as we said
earlier, spoke to reporters
after she survived her vote.
Unclear why
she survived her vote just by one vote
where the other two
representatives did not.
I'm also joined
by The Atlantic's Ron Brownstein.
Ron, talk a little bit
about some of this
in context and perspective.
Is this just about a violation of House
decorum rules that took place last week?
Clearly, they violated the rules.
They used a bullhorn.
If everybody did that,
that would be chaos.
But this is an unusual
and an extreme reaction to it.
Yeah.
Look, I mean,
it is unprecedented in Tennessee
and possibly in the country
to remove a legislator,
to expel a legislator
or effectively erase
the votes of their constituents
for this kind of infraction.
I think, Anderson,
you have to see this in the context
of what has been happening
across the red states on a wide range
of issues,
where you see
Republican controlled legislators
and governors
whose political power
is rooted
in their domination of non-urban,
predominantly white areas,
using that statewide power to override
the decisions of diverse,
racially diverse,
blue leaning
big cities and counties
on a wide range of issues.
I mean, you can look at
what's happening in places like Texas,
where they have taken
the state has taken over
the school district in Houston,
and they do so in Austin.
In Florida, where Ron DeSantis has fired
one elected Democratic prosecutor
and is moving against another.
Places like Georgia
and Missouri and Tennessee,
where they where they've
taken over
preempted process
neutral and policing powers
of local governments
and taking that power to the state.
And obviously
with nothing
from the states on curriculum
that effectively override
the ability of of localities
to set their own rules
on talking about race or gender
or sexual orientation.
It is a very consistent pattern
across the red states
where Republican coalitions
rooted in non-urban,
predominantly
white places are using their power
in the most.
And this may be the most
dramatic and egregious grant
to override the decisions
of local government.